it seemed to me but anyone I ever spoke
to and I've interviewed a lot of people
who spend time at the Playboy Mansion
women who have posed in Playboy it all
kind of seems like the same Mo when you
get there off the bus it's kind of like
well we want to dye your hair blonde we
want to get you dressing a certain way
you know my first day at the Playboy
Mansion I was in my acid wash jeans you
know it's a rock T-shirt with my
sneakers on with the little balls on the
socks you know and they were like you
know you can come to the Playboy Mansion
closet and get dressed for the next time
you come out and I thought well what
kind of clothes would be in the Playboy
Mansion closet right you didn't even
know what innocent little panel I wear
clothes it's almost like the Twilight
Zone they want to mold you into the same
person in a way David Chappelle used to
say going to the Playboy Mansion was
like the Twilight Zone like he thought
he saw a hundred of me from the back and
then they would turn around and not be
me right but it's true and then they
move you in right I mean like you get to
get a room there and you live there and
they feed you stay there I wouldn't stay
there I was nervous I don't know I mean
this is my Spidey Sense my Mr Magoo
thing I just always thought even when I
came here the first thing they said was
well let's go stay at the Playboy
Mansion I said no I'll stay at a hotel
then I stayed at the hotel and they
would call me and say Pamela we want you
to come for fight night and I'd say I'm
not fighting anybody they're like oh no
we're just coming to watch Like Mike
Tyson fight on the big screen but I
thought they want to meet a Jello
wrestle or something and they said no
you don't have to mud wrestle you're
fine I said okay good because I'm not
foreign